you're not extending enough on your
follow through follow through is
everything in golf just like life haha
don't you fine it's all your scarface
picture violent realistic movies on
movies howard not life now the stage a
stage is real real flesh-and-blood human
beings right out there in front of you
Buster look away got much popcorn that
would be row do you like the theater no
only alive on the stage I'll teach you
will see some instant if the Republicans
have an outlet in by now huh no no no
Republic and I are you gonna buy that
well I didn't you must it's your sacred
franchise Marty wanted to actually have
for each part of the film which is a
period piece for it to look like what
the films of the day were like so back
then this was early their to strip
Technicolor then it would go to
three-strip Technicolor and the ideas as
it got more modern he would go to you
know our moment you know the normal
Eastman colour stuff but unfortunately
we was screening it it got to the third
one he said it's a letdown I want my
Technicolor back so we wound up
extending the three strip stuff all the
way through Howard I'm gonna get on
famously with father grandmother and I'm
sure they're like you
once I get to know you so sorry when I'm
away now you're gonna be lonely just for
me oh oh that's my ex-husband Ludlow
father mother just mad about Lonnie the
hell is he doing here this is Howard
Bowen welcome no worries that is lunch
he liked here we did have an interesting
Nataly Kalmus moment on this movie the
final stages of grading and we were in
New York as Marty won't fly unless he
has to and so the editor Thelma
Schumacher was there and in one of these
scenes with the Technicolor three-strip
emulation that we do she also just sort
of says stop that dresses the wrong
color we're going well what do you mean
says we specifically picked a dress of a
certain color and that dress is the
wrong color up there and I had to
explain that well whatever color the
dress was this is the color it would
have wine wound up going through this
sort of photochemical process and it
would wind up with that collar on the
screen you know and she's like no we did
film tests it's not that color is this
but we didn't have this whole emulation
of this process back then but she would
have none of it we had a figure out some
way around it which we did but sure
enough I fly back to Burbank and go
across the street to our student go up
and someone says there's something for
you in the vault which is where all the
mail came and go in there and hanging up
is just rows and rows of boxes of film
and there
is the dress hanging on with a sign on
it that says this is the collar of the
dress and so we had to make it that
color but certainly there's something
that in some ways has been lost is it
would always shoot wardrobe tests and
and makeup tests all the time to see
make sure that the things were coming
through the same way and this is
something that seems with a few
exceptions a few rare exceptions to have
been lost